So when you look at that,
isn't that,
isn't that true?
We are overpopulated in some ways though with our technology.
But let me just make this point where we've got to this I gotta pee so bad.
What?
Go Go pee pee and come back home.
Finish five more minutes.
Cause I want to,
I want to get into the top.
You talk to Eddie,
talk some sense into him.
Tell him about Buzz Aldrin telling me about boy buzz Aldrin.
You know,
I'll tell you about buzz off.
He told me Christ,
I know.
Where are you going back.
Okay.
It's going to be Brown.
Cleveland browns.com.
I'm not allowed
both leaf.
Jamie,
Eddie,
how you doing?
I'm doing good.
So,
um,
what do you,
what do you think about the wide receiver
of the browns?
I don't think we can turn the talk to Brown said no,
unfortunately is okay.
Is there any conspiracy theory that you kind of are suspicious of?
There's gotta be at least one.
I definitely
like nine 11,
nine 11.
You think?
You know,
are you familiar with tower seven?
Yeah,
I would say from almost every story,
even though the stuff we've talked about before in the past,
I,
I don't believe the official and quotes.
Okay,
so you know,
the tower seven was the third tower that went down.
You're aware of that,
right?
I look more when,
when that comes up,
all of the surrounding information about,
uh,
what,
what wasn't in the buildings,
not the actual event.
I know the event happened.
I'm not,
I'm not so curious about that.
Did you see the video of tower seven fiscal free fall speed?
That's gotta be a little suspicious,
right?
Red Flag got to come up at least,
right.
If you're trying to,
if you're really trying to get to the truth,
you're like,
wait a minute.
I would say this more suspicious that a third building fell.
It wasn't,
it wasn't even a hit.
Exactly.
That's what the whole story is with tower seven and not only was it not touched
by a plane,
it went down at free fall speed and it's caught on video like five different
angles.
Right?
There's five different names.
No one's saying that it's fake footage.
That's tower seven to 47 storey,
skyscraper fucking fallen at free fall speed.
Some people are saying,
I got hit with a direct energy weapon.
Some people are saying that it was uh,
brought down like a controlled demo and like in Vegas,
like one of those buildings,
you know.
But regardless of how it was brought down,
you got to look at that video footage to go,
wait a minute and why is youtube telling you now I'm building seven footage
footage.
Why did it go [inaudible] ready?
I don't like 50 stations in 2001 and I'm sitting there,
that's actually,
I was on 120 stations.
I lost like 70% of her saying that it was an inside job.
I don't mean the firemen blow it up.
I'm watching Fox News,
CNN at my shoes and then I go get a pizza at four o'clock.
Well CBS radio back then and they go,
Solomon Brothers building seven is going to be brought down to controlled
demolition to say their buildings.
So I go back on air and announce building savins being brought down to see what
their buildings and for five,
five years,
everyone goes,
I'm crazy.
Then CNN and all of them archive it on the Internet and everyone's watching
Golding.
Seventh on
BBC,
ABC.
Let me ask CNN,
do you think happened with tower seven?
She and and ABC and CBS told me the government blow it up,
the government,
I mean you play the clips.
They go,
because all I get back,
we're blowing it up and the media,
he goes,
oh,
you mean the cops blow it up?
No,
the cops are told,
get back on the countdown.
I interviewed with comms like Jen explained to me.
Do you think that they had detonation set up already in the buildings next Joe,
which I used to always like try to follow it down.
What it means.
I don't know.
I've learned to go,
Hey,
I've got five different newscast when it happened.
And before in saying they blew it up,
I don't know what happened.
Is it possible that it collapsed because of those gigantic diesel fires?
Right.
And then the way hour one to two sevens is on building seven seven had a deer.
I had diesel tanks in the basement caught fire and they said it was an inferno
and they said it cooked through the nose.
Hold on a second.
It's always,
but I want to ask you this cause I don't know.
Oh yeah.
Right.
But they said that what happened was,
this is whoever the fuck explained it,
that was making these youtube videos that the fire had burnt through the
internal structure of the building.
It's such a high temperature that all of these floors,
how lax they pancaked and then it came.
But it never happened before.
Since right.
Never hasn't happened before.
Since that's a fact.
Here's,
here's the thing about those showns 18 years ago would argue every point and
say,
I knew what happened.
Okay.
The Alex Jones 2019 is honest.
Well,
I'm glad you're,
and I'm going to say I've seen him saying they blow it up and nobody can
describe it.
I don't know,
Joe,
what happened?
Right.
Well,
when you look at it the way it falls,
it falls exactly.
Looking controlled.
Demolition.
Exactly.
So it falls from the top down.
But if you actually want false peak,
right.
But if you watch the full video,
the center of it collapses.
Like there's a full video where you're looking at the top of the building and
the center of it collapses far before the outside does.
That's how they take,
they take out the elevator central thing first.
So do light up the Tuesday.
Do they do this with,
do they have it all set in advance?
So they knew that nine 11 was going to come and tutor.
She answered my question and please don't know.
And what they do is they take like some clip of me from 20 years ago or 18 years
ago going here's CBS News and they don't show it.
I mean I've got,
yes,
I've got easy possible that even though operation Northwoods happen,
Gulf of Tonkin was a conspiracy.
Is it possible that the internal fires in that building were so unbelievably hot
that it fucked up every floor and they really did pancake on top of each other
and then the exterior structure just collapsed?
Is that possible?
Because I'm not an engineer.
I've had the engineer's say it's not,
it's not possible at all.
And it,
here's the problem with,
they announced it fell on its own footprint 27 minutes before it dead on five
channels.
Damn baby.
She world.
Is that true baby?
She,
Shannon,
Shannon and CBS.
Joe,
I'm a,
I keep food.
I do too.
It was four o'clock I've been on ever since that morning on syndicated radio.
I drove down to the local pizza place at four o'clock got my page that was
eating it in the car and our CBS radio driving home and they shed little pseudo
live in mood or say whether our buildings too controlled demolition and the
Solomon brothers in building seven by the way,
we have these clubs now,
but no one archive stuff that,
so I go on there and I go,
yeah,
they just blow up a building.
Everybody started freaking out,
but here's the thing.
And then they blew it up.
How long does it take to set up explosives to the point where you could paint?
It normally takes a week.
A week.
That was the next story.
But then I interviewed,
yeah,
the head of emergency management for Newark.
Yeah.
And the loose change people got him on and he says,
no,
I was there.
They had bombs.
The CIA,
you know what was patient building?
Seven right?
Villa,
the CIA,
the FBI,
all it was it NSA as well.
See,
he always says,
oh,
I don't know.
He goes to his ass.
He's beyond.
No,
it's bullshit,
man.
Every fucking thing.
Just fucking say to yourself.
No.
Once you explain it to everybody.
Oh,
you're on there too.
It's like you did a better job than 40 fucking stories are fucking government.
Right.
So there's 40 with a diesel tank and pre rigged explosives in case shit.
Dude.
Man didn't believe.
And even though I heard CBS say they blow it up and even though I like to do is
we'll go,
Joe says firefighters blow it up because the government,
same thing.
Point you made is a good point.
Like I'm setting the government.
No,
I don't mean my grandpa was in the army.
If it really did pancake from the,
from the fire.
What a shit design.
Yeah.
What a terrible design be so mad at that.
Architects were the banks from underwriting laboratories is everyone.
I went and looked at the blueprint and into New York and I'm not defending what
you're saying because seven was built well,
it was looked at by lawsuits.
There were sued tower one and two though they were built with like bubblegum and
like bandaids.
Really?
Oh,
all those buildings were already leaning.
Oh No.
It was a big mob scam.
Yeah,
I know.
They already had.
They already had buckling in the wind.
Oh No.
Mathematicians Gash.
That was in like five years.
One building would collapse.
Oh fuck.
Oh my God.
There goes your argument each New York,
these buildings are built for shit and that's when he,
as you get older,
you know
some of them were built for shit.
Right?
For sure.
Right.
I don't,
yeah,
I mean especially back then when what is inside your back heel?
More tobacco.
I do have more tobacco,
but I'm just,
Kevin was a little bit more tobacco.
Yes,
for sure.
100% you know who Dr. Judy Wood is a no,
I do know she's,
she's got Dr. Judy Wood.
It's wrote a book called,
where did the towers go?
Yeah,
particle her story.
Her theory is,
this is just,
this is just some lady scientists lady.
She said based on the fact that there was this,
what she claims based on the video and the pictures that she has of,
uh,
where the towers collapsed.
She that her speaking for me,
sorry,
she's saying that there was no rubble.
The book,
the name of the book is called,
where did the towers go?
She said that direct energy weapons,
some kind of direct energy weapons justify the building's turn the buildings to
dusk because there was no rubble.
A dude gave me a book on that.
Let me see,
man,
you can't read this.
He's like,
no,
no.
He's in America and this gives in La.
He told me,
uh,
they use Tesla technology.
I was like,
what?
He can say,
you're Rog,
ask that question.
You know what?
For me,
it doesn't matter if it was dust the fied or they buttering them up in Las
Vegas,
style matters.
Here's those buildings,
in my opinion.